[Music]
so
oh overblown what
is that he use a different word yeah oh
that's the exact right word
yeah i think i just somewhat agree that
it's blown out of proportion because
i think what happens with social media
is a group of people
coined a term and now it's we're all
painted by it
like we are not in like a post i don't
know like
culture world you know like women are
being catcalled every day
and so like men are still i think
seen or experienced as like a predatory
presence
to women so like that's why i just don't
think it's like overblown i think it's
just
it's new if we were good men there
wouldn't be feminists
they wouldn't be attacking us they
wouldn't be hating us you have a lot of
guys who don't want to commit to
marriage you have a lot of guys who
can't call
so yes men have become toxic and once
again i have to be
i have to be consistent with all my
let's be clear men haven't become
toxic there's always been men that have
been toxic since installment
this whole idea of cat kong's whole idea
it's been there
yeah these ideas have been there for a
long time these are not new concepts
that are just happening now
even the things that are happening like
essentially that's been happening
so we need to stop talking like these
are new age things all right because it
does a disservice to our grandmothers or
great grandmothers and people who came
before us who had suffered through this
stuff okay this is not
a 20 20 thing it's not a 2000 thing so i
just don't like it whenever one paints
the present as the worst time in history
brother it's not
it used to be way worse before believing
i see
what you're saying but the way you're
framing it like this this word
moral is kind of we don't know what that
is anymore though well it's like it
sounds like you're saying like it's
men's job to be like the moral compass
of society
um it is i think
this guy's not a budget i i appreciate
it
i think you're saying that yeah guess
what i said then buy it yeah
this is what happens when a 20 year old
meets a 35 year old
it's everybody's but men if men want to
coin themselves as the leaders you have
to hold up to the good and the best
that's part of the problem though
like that's what i think toxic
masculinity or it's putting too much
pressure on yourself
i mean it's very obvious that we're
grappling with like
the history and the damage of like what
a world completely run by men
does to us that's why i think we're
talking about
toxic masculinity
you know what let's do something in the
chat why don't you guys all answer with
a question before as we're gonna answer
it
should the man pay for the first date
this is my answer if he asked her out
then yes we're talking about a toronto
normative
relationship because you got game off
just be like well i'm gonna wait for him
to pay because he's supposed to
and i just imagine gay couple like the
restaurant being like
so listen
whoever asks should pay that's me
personally sure and this is not even
just like i'm with with my date even my
friends i'm like yo y'all want to go
again
go to the spot i want to go out to eat
then i'll just pay for it you know
you know so that's generally how i look
at it i agree with that
[Laughter]
i like the way the old school ways work
they did work we just messed it up
so that's important to you to like take
that leadership role
tradition to be like the breadwinner i'm
the caretaker of society
i don't even like seeing it this way
once you give the woman the power
then you just demasculated yourself i
just i want to stick to what's made me
happy in my
oh my man going in okay he doesn't care
he's going to be the most important part
of this video because he's going to
contrast their views a lot yeah like
happy and my grandparents my parents
i'm just going to stick with it because
it works it's not perfect but it works
be a man playing support uh i think i
don't know i think we're just getting in
dangerous
territory when we start talking about
chivalry at the end of the day it's like
yo baby if you want to pay for this like
there is no hierarchy here like why why
no no no
you were me you could have made a good
course but when you went hey hey baby if
you want to pay for this
hey baby if you want i like the point
but the way he said it was
baby if you want to pay for this hey
baby
if you want to pay for this pay for this
pay for this page
if you want to pay for this you could
pay for everything but you didn't see
the way
he he he tucked in his chin like this he
was like baby and he
changed his voice baby if you want to
pay for this she was in a situation
right there
he plays himself in the thing but i
understand i see what you're thinking
baby if you want to pay for this baby if
you want to pay for this
and then get this i know what you want
you want to pay for this pay for this
maybe next time i'm like
i just got to check so i'll pay for it
wasn't this the first meal though
yeah the first one you only get one
chance to make a first impression
what does it matter if if it's a girl or
a guy it's 2019
and your logic shouldn't be like no
disrespect like
oh because my grandpa did it and it
worked for him then it works for me
if she's not going to date me that
second time because i didn't pay for her
i think i dodged the bullet okay let's
be honest i think these guys are
a bit in fantasyland all right and we
just have to be honest about it
generally the vast majority of time it's
men who are asking women out on the
first date
still general and women do
still to this date prefer to be courted
so understand that hey no matter how
much 2019
2021 it is a lot of those gender norms
are still very pervasive today you may
not like it you may not want them to be
there but they are the norm
so what i advise young men to not pay on
the first date
no especially if you're the one who
asked around you should be paying
it makes no sense but you want to go to
this restaurant i like yeah
it's on you baby what what's your idea
you made the move the suggestion
so just think about that today's video
is sponsored oh wait
all right you already know okay we're
ready today's video is sponsored by blue
chew
say it with us now blue chips it's time
for you to gain more confidence
and longer lasting experiences in the
bedroom with bluetooth tablets okay
you deserve better she deserves harder
get it together
bars listen bluechu is a unique online
service
that offers you the same active
ingredients
as viagra in cialis but in a chewable
form
and at a fraction of the cost and one of
the best parts is that you know
bluetooth it's an online service so you
don't need to go to the doctor and have
an awkward conversation with that person
all you gotta do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical
licensed professionals and once you're
approved we just ship it to your door
and we got a special deal just for you
guys
you can try bluetooth for free when you
use promo code abba all right
and all you gotta do is pay for the five
dollar shipping that's bluechew.com
using promo code abba
and get your first month free so big
shout out to bluetooth for sponsoring
this video
i've had worried yeah i think a lot of
men have you guys
yes man hasn't you had questions if you
were a teenager you must have had
some insecurities at some point because
growing up everyone was always talking
about like who you probably got a tiny
dog you're like damn
why you're going through puberty and all
those insecurities asking that questions
like asking
did you ever have insecurities jimmy
like
i think everyone kind of goes to that
journey at some point
raised in a foreign country where dong
size is not discussed
i don't believe that or this guy is like
packing packing pause and he's just like
nah obviously from the but the problem
is you're always comparing yourself to
prawn
yeah so when you look at that you're
like i'm not packing like them
especially when you were a kid yeah
because you have you know you've never
had a girl tell you as yet maybe you did
yeah i don't believe these things
it's just a normal thing to be worried
about like when you're
growing up like you're like am i normal
you know like
i hate this um i guess like when i was
younger i was like whoa bring your
ass bring your ass yeah on the other
side
that's right no one's talking about when
you're comfortable it'd be like asking
have you ever been insecure about your
looks and you're like when i was
then you were then you were that's it
that's all this is not but like
eventually i was like nah i'm fine then
walk your ass back on the other side
bruh
you didn't you didn't hear the question
just like bring into my awareness how
impressionable
and like how much of our lives and our
masculinity is defined by when we're
kids
when everybody's like oh you gotta have
a big you gotta have a big and all you
see is like only time you see it
is on it's like 14 inches then it's like
mine doesn't look like that yeah then of
course you're gonna like start thinking
about it versus
oh now you're moving back
all right oh
oh there you go there you go
okay okay
there you go hey man you know what
everyone after getting new information
they can change their mind so that's
cool
that's cool because what he said was it
made a lot of sense because i remember
the first time i saw porn when i saw
black guys
i was like you didn't have to mention
the race like this that's all
you know some white kid you know they
know they know
chicago all right get it guys i'm not
like that
as i got older i perfected my craft i've
never had a problem
yeah yeah i'm not even going to front
you bro ball [ __ ] don't have a choice
they yeah they don't they the way the
light reflects on their head during in
the dark man
they got to put in some extra work i'm
not even joking bro
when you bald you got to do a little
extra something you got to grow a couple
inches you got to get a little bit
bigger
because the bald life is not an easy
life nope it's all about
it's not the size of the boat it's the
motion of the ocean it's not the size of
the bulb
you know you know whatever it's
[Music]
you just love a woman you embrace each
other and it's just i've never had a
problem with a woman
since then i think for younger guys
this is the concern that i'm realizing
is like
maybe if these discussions were more
open about size and whatever
and that really over time it all becomes
okay
and it's fine um maybe that would help a
lot
four hypothetical you're just a teenager
chock full of testosterone going through
puberty insecure surrounded by other
insecure teenagers with raging hormones
and you're gonna latch on to whatever
ecological trying to instill a sense of
logic into a bunch of teenagers is
very difficult very difficult so
you know i think insecurities are just
part of that portion of life if it you
know and if it's not your dong it's
gonna be your build it's going to be
your height it's going to be your acting
whatever boys is going to be everything
yeah so so
it's kind of going to be your pelosi the
only thing you could do
is just let them know that it's going to
be okay and try to give them but they're
probably still going to be insecure
takes time to build that kind of
confidence in yourself there's no way
we're ever going to get point to society
where teenagers come out with like
ultimate confidence
leave your comments below but i wish i
would agree
be real be real
at first when i saw you know and talking
to my friends a lot of
family a lot of people in the south
they're like these women should have
spoke up a long time ago
and then i had to like step aside and
really process it for myself
and be like you know what she didn't
feel comfortable and it wasn't a she
wasn't in a society in a place
where it was acceptable for her to say
anything about it so now that they have
the platform and the
ability i'm like that's amazing speak
your truth
okay i wanna hear your thoughts what do
you think about what
if i support a mutual movement yeah i'm
gonna be like this i understand the
necessity of it
so i somewhat agree okay but i
i understand the flaws of it as well so
that's why i somewhat agree
somewhat agree both are very uh
very are very uh important in that it's
not just
agree it's not just somewhat it's just
not it's i somewhat agree
yeah there is a necessity there and and
and we have to understand how it is
just the the way that just judicial
system works and everything and stuff
i can understand how people are going
that and we need to have a change i get
that
i get all of that so i somewhat agree
yeah
i think for me you know the interesting
thing is like prior to that movement
there were absolutely no conversations
that i'd had at school
or in my personal life or with my family
or
even brought up in front of me or around
me on television anything
about the ideas of what consent is what
pressure looks like what all these
concepts look like
we were thrown into the dating life
blind straight up and you have to figure
it out
you have to figure it out and you know
unless you went to a college campus you
never heard these terms you know from
someone me you just joined the military
you didn't hear about this
you're just hearing us these words these
terms now because it was part of the
college campus
campuses back in the days so all that
even now you're hearing about these
terms
but back then it was same as yeah so so
2016 2017 was interesting transition
period because i was hearing about the
stuff and i was like oh
okay i have someone learning to do
because nobody told me you can't talk
like this nobody told me
oh you have to ask and look i'm not
taking everything yet i don't think all
of it's good
but it was an important thing just to
make us realize
that there was a separation between the
two genders in regards to what happened
in the bedroom
and that was a problem it was very much
so and i think it's good for us to be
able to learn from those
now of course much like preach or
certain aspects of it i'm going to
disagree with but i don't think it
invalidates its necessities
and it uh brought to light the very
strong fact that
we don't talk about stuff in the bedroom
yeah there's a lot going on
so yeah what do you tell a child who is
accused of
by a woman has his whole life destroyed
and then people just go huh
there's always going to be people that
take advantage of it it's not going to
be perfect
we're figuring it out as we go but i
think it's done more good than it's done
bad i think i think we get to
acknowledge the bad though
like i think yeah like that's why i'm
doing like this thing is like
for us to say like oh he did that to me
and all of a sudden now we've like
vindicated that guy is like vilified
like there is no chance of like
him having a say in the conversation
trying to get that conversation
like this mob mentality is bad i agree
with that but
i don't think that's exclusive to the
metoo movement but we're using it right
now to say
oh that person is bad oh [ __ ] that
person there's no further conversations
being happening
if it's a movement to say yes okay this
arc we've created of men and women which
is a result of the way men are expected
to act that women are expected to act
let's have those conversations and
everything changes and i'll be over
there all
day and let's also be honest about the
fact that
this conversation has never included
women who do this stuff
never even when you try to include them
you're being bashed
yeah never never never never never never
never
two one go
yeah i'd say i agree i'd say i agree i
just probably don't
want to do it that often because i'm
just like it's not
it's not necessary but yeah it's not
because you don't do it that you're not
comfortable
yeah i agree i'm comfortable doing it
but i'm gonna choose
what's better for me i know that is me
in certain uh situations that i am
showing my emotion
is not going to be beneficial to me or
me in that situation
so i would be comfortable to do it but i
understand
that i could i could pay i'm comfortable
paying for a lot of things
yeah doesn't mean that i could do i
could drive my car with my feet doesn't
make it a good [ __ ] idea
my suspicions that for him it has
something to do with his family
it's been like harped upon me for years
that like showing my emotions were bad
and like me trying not to
be gay i'm like no like i don't want to
show these emotions because i'm not gay
i can't be gay like i'm not supposed to
be gay like the church tells me my dad
tells me my mom tells me everybody's
telling me
i'm not for black folks it's almost
always linked to the family yep
yep definitely not supposed to be gay so
like
just understanding that at 25 now 26
like i'm over here like okay like
oh you're insecure okay that's what that
feels like oh you're sad
that's what that feels like i can now be
aware of those things but to
show them to other people right now is
like really hard for me
i do feel like i'm very verbally
like about my emotions with my wife but
i wouldn't agree completely because i'm
not like that with anyone else
i mean i just failed a college class and
i was crying about it to my wife
but no one else at school saw me cry you
know
i specifically texted my there isn't
something necessarily wrong with that
in my opinion you know like um i don't
think every emotion that you feel
necessarily has to be expressed in
public nor do i think it's a good thing
you know there's a word called privacy
you know what that's for private things
and some emotions are fine
kept in private right the same way
there are certain things that i would
say about my future wife that i might
not say in public
but i would say them in private right
that's not me being unable to show my
emotions it just means
i know how to sequence certain things
for certain environments i'm not going
to tell you guys
my my social insurance number that's not
me being
a secretive person that's me
understanding that certain things are
best kept in certain areas right
there's a difference between being
comfortable and not being your business
yep it's not your business yeah it's not
because my doors are not
open that i'm not an open person it's
just my house i want to keep my door
closed this is a private place
specifically texting my wife make sure
the kids are asleep by the time i come
home because i just knew i was going to
be like
as soon as i stepped through that
threshold to my house i was just going
to let go and i didn't want them to see
that but like the next day i sat down
and i had that conversation with them
like hey i just wanna let you guys know
you know your dad didn't pass this class
and they're like oh are you okay and i'm
like yeah of course you just cry in
front of your kids man
i remember like seeing my dad cry for
the first time when his mom died
and i remember like imprinting that in
my mind as like wow you know like
my dad can be upset and that was like a
an important thing to witness it's
reality emotion
yeah it's real i was raised by two
parents that i never
ever saw cry the effect that that had on
me
was by the time one of them passed away
very suddenly
i didn't really seem to be affected at
all so i've actually had to
do a lot of therapy on that this thing
about masculinity not being able to show
your emotions
is very bad i um i think the part about
the parent
crying a lot emotion is not just crying
but i see what you're saying yeah
whatever yeah i think people always link
it to that and i think that's already an
interesting conversation and of itself
yeah because when you say you're
emotional oftentimes is
you're crying but it's not that it's not
that if someone's like yo
you're being emotional right now if they
celebrate you that's them being
emotional
right right if they're angry with you
that's them being emotional people don't
recognize those so
it's important to recognize i think
they're basically saying vulnerable yes
okay i think that's probably the word
that they're looking for yeah and i'll
say this
i don't have an issue with having seen
my dad cry
but i think if i would have saw him cry
a lot or often
i probably would have had an issue with
it because that's
the person who i lean on right that's
the rock the pillar
they're always in emotional distress or
consistently in that
i don't think that's a stable spot me
personally now of course
to each their own i'm not trying to say
that if you do that it's a problem live
your best life
but i don't think it's a good idea
for me as a man if i was to race kids to
be constantly crying in front of them
they got to lean on me they have to look
at me as their father in terms of like
that
sense of authority yeah of course we're
gonna have a very close relationship but
okay i'm gonna just take this because
i'm always used to this like
leadership positions uh military
if you constantly saw your leader in
distress or crying you question their
leadership
subconsciously you will unfortunately
that's the way it works
that's why when it comes to these kind
of things they often go to other
uh other leaders to do that if you do it
in front of your soldiers or you do it
in front of your platoon
it's like yeah guess what they're gonna
look at you differently
they're gonna look at you differently if
you don't succumb to emotions like
whether it is
always being angry lashing out crying uh
if you're very stable it shows a certain
sort of
stability yeah right yep let me tell you
you ever seen those punch cards you get
from like frozen yogurt spots
yes right let me tell you as a man you
get a few stamps you get a few holes
that you get to click in
right before you get your collect uh uh
get the f
out of here out of this relationship
card okay try it
have a wife and cry in front of her all
the time have a girlfriend
crying for all the time watch what's
going to happen subconsciously
and you can see articles of this people
have written about this so many times
like yes i know i'm supposed to be open
to this kind of emotional beauty but
like
it turned me off all the time all the
time because they lean on you like
especially if you subscribe to the
traditional gender roles they lean on
you
to be that pillar even when you don't
even when you don't you know and we've
seen an article about that
even when you don't she wanted them she
wanted she was like i i'm okay with that
man wearing a dress i'm okay and once
her significant hunter was doing that
she was like oh
yeah i can't help it though yeah no you
can't
and and people are giving me the
comments so i would be fine with it
there's what you
say and what you're going to do in that
situation and most men
know either from experience or from
lessons
that if they were to be constantly
emotionally vulnerable in that way
that most y'all i'm not saying some
emotional visibility is not good
i agree with you it's fine but crying a
lot
often i don't recommend it so that's my
advice to y'all but maybe i'll disagree
what do you think no i agree yeah you're
not gonna cry for your kids all the time
no well i'm not someone that cries
i'm not someone that cries yeah but even
if you were like in distress or having
mad problems
you know what i mean no you wouldn't
show that to the kids i'm not i'm not a
person that
i'm supposed to hold it together you
know what i mean already i'm not someone
that does and that's not
who are you starting to be amazing shut
the [ __ ] up it ain't about that it's
really just
i'm not someone that cries yeah okay
there's people that cry a lot
i don't and and get out of the
and weakness i just stay stable
because you still you show stability you
do it for your kids you do it for your
wife your source ability i got this
doesn't mean that at some point you need
yeah you could you could show
something but you have to you have to
choose when you show your emotion and
where you show them that's it
because at the end of the day you have
to show stability it shows a certain
stability
doesn't mean that you have to hide it at
some point i could have conversation
with my wife be like you i feel like
this i feel like that i feel like
whatever
it doesn't change that yeah but i'm not
gonna always gonna show it like that
man man it's bad it's bad no at some
point i gotta think about what's going
on
and what i gotta do to make things
better you understand what i'm saying
so yeah i'm gonna have to sit down and
talk about my feelings all day every day
no problem
but i'm not someone that cries when i
need to cry i will that's not a that's
not even a problem it's not like oh
i'm crying i'm not gonna hide i'm not
gonna hide in the bathroom if i
if i need to cry i'ma cry but no i'm not
going to use i'm not going to use that
every time i'm not using but i'm not
i'm not going to cry all the time like
that in front of people and be like no
sometimes like
let's get done got to be done here i
agree i agree
hey listen what do you think let us know
what do you think about crying not even
just crying just emotion and being
vulnerable all of that you know i mean
subscribe
subscribe subscribe comment
and yeah share also shout out to you
really this is a good video
true that was a good video good
[Music]
what job can't do